[Music]
from sailors who were turned into pigs
nymphs that sprouted into trees and a
gaze that converted the beholder to
stone
Greek mythology brims with shapeshifters
the powerful gods usually changed their
own forms at will but for mortals the
mutations were often unwanted one such
unnerving transformation be felled the
spinner
Arachne Arachne was the daughter of a
tradesman who spent his days dyeing
cloth the deepest shades of purple she
had a flair for spinning the finest
threads weaving them into flowing fabric
and creating magnificent tapestries
people flocked to watch her hands flying
across her loom as if thread sprung
directly from her fingertips
but as praised for her work grew so did
her pride Arachne could often be heard
boasting about her skills declaring that
her talent surpassed anyone elses mortal
or divine she refused to see weaving as
a gift from the gods
rather she flaunted it as her own
personal genius unfortunately the
goddess of wisdom and crafts Athena
overheard Arachne making these claims
planning to teach the ungrateful girl a
lesson Athena disguised herself as an
old woman and stole amongst the mortals
she berated Arachne in public how dare
the weaver claim herself greater than
the gods but Arachne only laughed barely
looking up from her loom provoked the
old woman threw off her cloak to reveal
her true form
if Arachne insisted on defaming the gods
athena would challenge her to a contest
directly masking her shock at the
appearance of the grey eyed goddess
Arachne accepted the challenge athena
drew up her own glittering loom as a
great crowd gathered to watch
the weavers began eyes fixed and
shuttles blurring Athena conjured wisps
of cloud from above and slender threads
of grass from below in a spectacle of
strength she wove tremendous scenes that
showed the power of the gods
Poseidon riding the waves Zeus firing
Thunderbolts and Apollo hurtling across
the sky in Athena's splendid tapestry
the glory of the gods dwarfed mortal
life but Arachne had no interest in
boosting godly egos her tapestry showed
the gods abusing their power squabbling
amongst themselves drinking and bragging
and meddling in the lives of mortals she
represented Zeus as a philanderer
transfiguring himself to ensnare women a
swan for Leda a bull for Europa a shower
of gold for Dennehy Arachne then turned
to the misdemeanors of other gods from
Pluto's abduction of Persephone -
Bacchus 'as wild pursuit of a riggan II
even though she cast the gods in the
most unflattering light a rack knees
work shone with her dazzling skill her
tapestry was almost alive filled with
movement and lustrous colors that winked
triumphantly when Athena saw a rack
knees undeniably better and flagrantly
subversive work she flew into a rage and
turned on the human Weaver Iraq knees
glee dimmed as she felt her body
shrinking and contorting her fingers
waved wildly as her arms stuck to her
sides and black hair sprouted all over
her body
the goddess left Arachne with a single
spool of thread unfurling from her belly
a slim reminder of her human talent for
challenging the assumption that the gods
were untouchable Athena had shrunk her
adversary into the first spider to this
day
Arachne and her children spin out her
penance or is it undaunted persistence
in the shadows of giants if you enjoyed
the myth of Arachne check out this
playlist for more epic tales
[Music]